welcome to this video playing chromis
from Norway five out of nine I got
against him and I should play I'm white
right it was stupid
what am I doing here and okay let's see
the Queen's Gambit okay
playing that chick Goren well who I have
no idea whatsoever about this I know
that see 594 is the way to claim okay
some I'm starting with that Jack we just
takes that I didn't expect but why not
yeah why not keep trying to just play
for for development
yeah but I understand yeah this is just
very healthy for black he's got good
pieces probably just Knight f6 castles I
have no sorry I have no clear plan in
this position I can maybe try to do
something on the queenside
you related to rooks see one might be
five those kind of things but black can
always go like a s6 Bishop d7 or or or
even um even play for c6 at the right
moment okay it's doing something
entirely different
he wants to play with f5 no certainly
possible maybe I can just prepare a form
so f5 I'm going to play an F form and to
be honest I think this should favor me
somewhat threatening to take on e5 now
with d6 check so there is there is need
for him to I mean f5 is a move that it
looks active but it also makes
really takes bishop takes six chick
so it's claiming that this is nothing at
all for me maybe he's right but okay I
can do this and go Bishop f4 urges which
is also also okay the problem is f5 is a
move that basically kills the bishop on
CA that makes this bishop a very
problematic piece and hmm you wonder is
it it plays it like nothing is going on
here ever
but isn't this really good for me like
isn't this good night here and d6 check
and stuff like that and that good hmm
Knight B fire what is he doing then
Quincy five on what is things I have
before in the mix also
[Music]
nighty forum
if I go d6 check here you can take
that's really that is really happening
then but this is just okay 94 I also
have Queen d4 which is not bad
[Music]
okay so d6 zoom not
I can also just move the bishop I mean
this is actually quite strong if I move
the bishop 497 like here this is very
simple but also quite good yeah 25 97
wins in exchange for for very little and
what is his move actually Queen b6
it just takes his heaven when he has
moved the Queen tons of times
well I have used this time to play rook
e1 rook c1 and so on yeah I mean it
pretty much has to play Queen b6 here
but what else is there
the noise Knight c7 rook b8 looks pretty
awful
hmm
and I'm not quite sure what is what is
calculating him okay when they after all
yeah maybe a computer can if I hire them
could be interesting but well I'm not a
comp so what is this fish should be
seven does what he wants to do I'm
thinking about Quincy fire for Lupe's
seven but I mean this is also just good
right come on let's play that try to
keep it simple Bishop takes rook cheeks
and then Queen d8 okay so I'm going to
take with the pawn to have Bishop takes
at five in the position
okay so Queen somewhere
Queenie 623 or something 94 Queen g3 is
quite good yeah one minute thirty
threatening to take on f5 as well so I'm
not sure he has some slowest move
maybe Bishop c4 is also a very simple
but effective effective thread okay that
I don't get it all to be honest
[Music]
I can take f7 yet Jesus 492 or something
he says some trick like that that would
be really disappointing some stupid
backlink stuff yeah take stakes 92 but I
could have check on see age right I have
to check here time warning yeah I didn't
see that beforehand that was lucky
black resigns I mean lucky sometimes you
you overlooked things but it's not fatal
or this was made into camp no I was just
thinking okay I'm like three pawns up
and and his position is a wreck so I
wasn't looking for a checkmate Queen c3
is pretty pretty good this is just like
+5 yeah the thing is this is this is the
the funny line check check and I'm
losing quite amazingly maybe maybe not
losing maybe I can get some kind of
miracle fortress draw it well it's
irrelevant totally um yeah it simply
didn't develop I mean I think here if we
start all the way back I'm not really
sure that f5 is a great idea this kind
of thing maybe after ninety eight it's
kind of kind of yeah who said he has to
say B this kind of thing but yeah I'm
definitely much better
look see one yeah this is this is easy
oops cheeks I want eggs went here
Queenie choice also on Bishop cheeks
yeah that was a pretty fine game
actually can be can be satisfied with
that I mean I didn't really only hear
after Bishop said I saw those tricks but
she have crossed Queen c3 is much much
stronger and made into yeah yeah yeah he
he has something better yeah but like
not taking well but after this I just I
just have to make sure that I'm not
blundering something very super Jim like
this this kind of move is is just very
reliably winning betrayed Queens and
it's three pawns so it's it's a win okay
I hope you like that thanks for watching